hi thank you very much um
so we have just seen avi uh
you know using all sorts of advanced
machinery
and you know this talk will be
more basic so this is based on
joint works with amigo the student of
mine
eric miles who was a student of mine
he's now a postdoc at ucla um and
elimination
whose faculty are technical
okay so the starting point
of this work is the classical result
that threesat is np complete um
okay so because i need to fix some
notation for the rest of the talk
let me go through what this means okay
consider some computation which may be
you know deterministic and which runs in
time t
and here t can be polynomial in the
input length
or it can be much bigger like
exponential and the setting of
exponential will be the one that's most
relevant for our work
then there exists an efficient reduction
map
r that takes any input to the
computation and
enough puts attrition f which is
satisfiable if and only if
the computation outputs one or accepts
all right
so there are many things which are
interesting to optimize about
such reductions uh the first one that
you may think about is the length of the
formula fee
okay and there was a series of works uh
decades ago
that have shown that uh it's possible to
achieve a fee of size
quasi-linear in running time t okay
which is the best possible up to these
polylog factors
okay and the second thing is the
complexity
of the reduction map r
okay so it is well known
that if you allow resources
to be at least as big as the length of
the formula
this computation is essentially trivial
okay it just amounts
to projecting uh on to the closest of
the formula fee
and i'm and i'm not going to make this
thing formal because our focus is on a
different setting
where the land where the resources
of the map are much much less in the
length of the formula
specifically uh we seek what i'm going
to call
close explicit reductions are
that have the following property and
they take this input both the input x
to the computation and an additional
input i
which is a an index to a clause of the
formula
and they should have put that clause
efficiently
just with respect the length of the
index i which is logarithmic in the size
of the formula
okay so to make this thing visual
here is how a possible output of the
reduction would look like okay it gets
an input i
and x and it spits out a clause
which is a three variables uh some of
which
may be negated all right what's the
x i see that yeah
x is the input to the computation let me
go back
one slide there's a machine m which runs
in time t
and the machine r takes an input x to
this machine okay and i put that threes
out
okay so here in this new framework i
have his input
both x and i okay however
in this talk i'm going to ignore x okay
and i'm just going to focus on the
computation as a function of i
okay so just what's the cost of output
in the clause however
uh dealing with x is not easy and
requires a separate argument
okay i'm not going to go through it okay
right so who cares about the stringent
notion of
explicitness actually this thing is
central to a number of important results
okay so the the well-known result
that if you take your favorite mp
complete problems
and you make a succinct version out of
it this becomes any expert complete
relies exactly on close explicitness and
here the setting is that the running
time is exponential in
yin the length of the formula doesn't
have to be
quasi but can be quality at least for
this version
and you sure you should be able to
output the i's clause in time polynomial
in the length of
the index okay and this notion is also
important for lower bounds like for
example the lower bounds the fourth set
that
we have like the ones in this paper and
and many others
um rely on close explicit reductions and
the setting here is that the running
time is polyen
the length of the formula critically has
to be quasi linear okay this thing
the quality size there will not be
enough for this
and the output of the clause should be
doable in time a polynomial in the size
of the index
and also space selenium if you want the
tightest results
okay and recently uh the notion of
crucifiedness has
you know has been brought to the
forefront by william's
remarkable uh connection between lower
bounds and satisfiability okay
um so specifically with williams
connection
uh if you want to prove a lower bound
against the circuit class c like for
example
if you see zero then you benefit and you
benefit
from having a close expedited reduction
where the competition of the clause is
done within the same class against which
you're proving the lower bound
okay and here the setting is that the
running time
is exponential the length of the formula
critically again
is quasi-linear and again the
computation should be done
within the same class against your
proving against which you're proving
driver bound
okay okay so what was known about
these reductions uh not much actually
so there is a result which appears in a
paper by laura storen
and wiederson in which for the simple
notion in which the length of the
formula is polynomial in the computation
they get a composition of the clauses in
s0 okay so what i mean by this again is
that
there is a circuit ac 0 of size adjust
polynomial in the index
to a clause which cannot put the closest
okay
this maybe it's also for quran or
whatever yeah so
of course yeah okay good so i think
other people
okay uh just you're never sure if you
want you know the big
so okay so uh if you get about
the you know the the tights
bounce on the sides of the formula then
uh in this pcp
paper they give reduction also in which
um the compression is done in nc1 okay
so and that's pretty much all that was
known okay and in fact the
more efficient reductions were
considered by some to be hard
or perhaps even impossible okay
so i mentioned earlier that uh williams
you know william's technique can benefit
from
from such reductions and
so this means that in his proof uh he
has to
yes he has to use a little workaround
to get the lower bound which also means
that his connection
was not as tight as one could have hoped
for okay and i will come back
to this in a second okay so what do we
do
we prove that in fact you can have this
close explicit reductions which are
very efficient okay so you can reduce
computational transit time t to three
sat
instances of the of the right size
quasi-linear
and each output bit of the um
each bit of the reduction just depends
on a constant number of bits
of the index okay so it has constant
locality
in the index this is a class of
functions which is also known as local
constant legality nc 0 or junta
okay
so the dependence on x is also a
constant legality
if your computation
if t is true the n is what
if t is 2 to the n so in the setting of
expansion time you get cosine
if the rain time is poly and you must
pay in x and there's no way around it
okay but if it's uh
yeah if the rain time is exponential
then you can encode
x into the reduction map and preserve
the control galley but but that requires
an argument
okay uh yeah
i should be like so you can probably
make this linear time in some turing
machine mode but we did not
go through it he asked the what's the
running time of r
and the answer is that you can probably
uh you make it a linear time in
turing machine model say but i didn't
check that that would be like
order log the running time
order you know their time in
input simple to use
the input is i and you just put one
close input
have the same length okay so you could
probably make this linear time
in the input length okay so i'm confused
okay good isn't it constant no
each output so it's not putting many
beats so it cannot be constant
it's happening so to to make this
completely visual
here is our possible clause in the
output can look like
okay so you give me i this is a possible
clause each of these variables has a
bunch of bits how many bits
it's about length of i okay
and you also have three sign bits for
this thing so
each of these bits so each bit of the
representation of each variable
just depends on a constant number of
bits of i okay
yeah so the exponent in the log
uh that is i'm going to get do you get
it down to
close to one or so uh probably not yeah
probably it's not very optimized you
know
you probably can but yeah we're going to
borrow but
is that is that clear
so this is pretty much it's taking a
length of my bits in input and
the output is about three times length
of i
about okay
right so this model is fairly restricted
in particular
uh this maps are can't even add one in
binary
okay so with constant regard you can't
even add one in binaries and i will come
back
to this to tell you where it's a problem
okay um in fact we get a number of other
reductions which have in cam
which have incomparable features
okay and i just want to highlight one
here
um so in the previous slide i mentioned
constant locality
but what about um getting the locality
like two or maybe even one
okay so we don't know it may be
impossible
but for the specific application of
getting overbound
salah williams in fact we give an error
which is
a reduction which is as efficient as
possible so
it has locality one that means that the
map is doing nothing essentially just
rewiring the edges and
uh it's like the circuit that's
computing the clause
isn't there okay so this gives a zero
red
um application for the
zero red uh cost for the application
uh of lower bounds so rims and gives
some of the tightest results and i'm
going to mention them uh
okay now that's equivalent you're saying
it's a projection right yeah so it's a
reject yeah
it's a rejection
they're all so as long as your circuit
is yeah as long as you
can negate things that you just negate
and rewire
so as long as you can swallow the knots
okay
so the cost of computing the clothes is
zero in then in
reasonable uh in a reasonable commodore
and so i want to tell you how what
consequences these things are
these things have and that's what i'm
gonna
discuss now
so first uh just uh some background on
williams connection so sorry that comes
afterwards
so first is just some simple
consequences
so uh just to get to the same page
so i mentioned that uh you know succinct
threesat and succinct recoloring being
any expert complete relies on close
explicitness reductions
so and now we get that this this
problems
uh remain any extra complete even
if they're encoded by nct circuits okay
and we also get a slightly strong graces
c
zero clover bound okay so whatever
williams can do we can shave off
just because just a little bit okay
but the more interesting uh consequences
are for a
somewhat tighter connection between
satisfiability
and the glower bounce following williams
so first of all a reminder that
uh when i say lower bound uh as in
williams i'm gonna mean
a lower bound for a function in e next
or uni e to the mp okay and when i say
algorithm are just going to mean uh
something which runs
faster than a brute force by super
polynomial amount
okay so in williamspear
uh you can get an overbound for circuit
of size s
and depth d if you have a star algorithm
for size which is a polynomially bigger
like s3c
and depth c times t okay and
a high level improvement is that with
this constant
reduction so we just need it's algorithm
for sizes c times
s and depth d plus c okay and this
constant c
now uh really screw uh really tighten
the screws
and we try to make them as small as
possible and i wanna
i want to tell you about that
so first of all uh we get uh a
connection between
uh cell algorithms and rubber bounds for
a
number of new classes which have been
studied in the past
okay so for all these things so these
are four classes
and and for each of these if you have a
algorithm now you get a new cloud bound
so this includes linear side circuits
and two classes
which are from valiance semi-paper
linear size log depth and near size
series parallel
okay and we also get for
quasi-polynomial cement
which would be a significant extension
of williams result
so all these things could not be
obtained before because of the loss
in the in the connection
okay and
something which is interesting uh is
that these things
can be related to assumptions about a
case out
okay and i'm going to tell you about
this now the first such
connection is actually in williams paper
so he shows remarkably
that if the eth is false
exponential time however it is then you
have a linear size
circuit overbound okay and in this paper
we also give an alternative proof of
this which is basically one line so you
just apply coclav into the previous
result
okay so so let me go back one slide if
you can improve a connection for linear
side circuits
you can just reduce in a size circuits
to a threshold instance
okay so it's just one line with this
framework
but we can do uh we can do more so now
we also get lower bounds if the strong
adh
is false okay this time there were bound
is for linear size
series pilot circuits
and we get other lower bounds
and assumptions which still don't have a
name okay
okay so and i want to tell you one more
thing
uh which is about making the constant as
small as
possible so
recall that uh 3n lower bounds is not
known so for general circuits under the
full basis so we don't know
how to prove that so it's a very modest
goal perhaps but you know
let's see what we can do so
we can now show that you will have such
lower bound
uh if you can place threesat in time
1.07 to the end
okay and in fact if you are happy with
the fact with the lower bound for a
function which puts two bits so we can
it's enough to get three certain time
one point one to the end okay so
uh the record is the three satin time
one point three four
okay by these people here like building
on previous works
uh there's still a gap but still i want
to emphasize these results because it
seems to be the first time that
uh this numerical value here uh has an
application for
complexity killer so if you balance
if you had one plus epsilon to the end
well would that give you
er it would be a much much more i mean
if epsilon becomes
very small it becomes a much better than
it would be like
what's that it becomes like foreign
okay so so i want to make one last point
about the
consequences about uh whether you know
this result to simplify
uh the proof that that next is not in
let's see
zero um and to answer this question
let's recall that
williams uses as black box previous
reductions
so if you said that you take hours as a
black box the proof
is simpler okay in fact that's how he
presented that the
book camp thank you in fact
if you just want this it's enough to get
a
reduction which runs in video which is
much simpler and i will tell you
in a second how it's done and this thing
was done independently by
kobansky and vanmecabik
any questions about this otherwise i'm
going to move
to the proofs so i want to
tell you how um we prove that these
local reductions
result and along the way i want to tell
you about some
background material which which which i
think is uh
is exciting it should be should be known
more broadly
right good okay so our goal
is is this first i'm going to forget
about threesat okay and i'm going to
think of circusat
okay so i want to uh so i have some
computation which runs in time t and i
want to reduce it to a circuit such
as instance c which has
quasi size okay
and uh what i need to do is that i have
a map
r which has constant frugality and
given an index side to a gate in this
circuit it should be able to output
the type of of that gate if it's or and
or constant and the children of this
gate with constant legality
okay so that's efficient because the
standard reduction from circuit set to
threesome
preserves constant regularity okay
so how do you do how do you do this so
the
standard way perhaps to get uh
such small circuits is to use the pip
injury and feature oblivious
simulation um however it's not clear how
you get this constant required result
from that okay many of us
but even if it is it seems quite
complicated
okay um
however uh gurevich and schiller
introduced an alternative way of
simulating computation
which i'm going to call this sort and
check technique
which seems useful however in their
paper
if you want to use it you still go back
to the pip engineering feature oblivious
simulation so instead we use a variant
by phantomic okay which is pretty cool
uh which is just like gurevich and
schiller but at the critical point which
i'm going to mention in nasa i'm going
to use the sorting networks
and by doing so um here it's the pip
interior and fischer simulation
okay so this variant
which i've described in a second seems
to be strangely unknown
or well known it was actually
rediscovered by
students in my students of mine in a
class that i was teaching we actually
spent months
doing it then we put it online and after
one hour we got an email from america
which saying
with a pointer to the section in a
survey
where it does the same thing so the
students lost confidence about you know
push them to continue working and then
we got
this result which which was then
rejected but
uh that's uh that's okay um
okay so um
so how does it work so uh here's how the
circuit looks like
uh and i wrote it on on the board but
because of a technical problem i
couldn't finish the
rolling so there's a band so the input
to the circuit
are a bunch of configurations i'm just
going to to write the sizes here
we have size order of vlog d
there are these checks circuits which
have size the point log t
and the third part which are size
c times point of t okay so with this
picture in mind
i can now describe uh
what this where stimulation does
so so the input to the circuits at
instance
c is a is a series of t configurations
where each configuration uh just takes
order of block t
bits and encodes the state the timestamp
of the machine and it has pointers and
contents
of a constant number of memory sets
so you don't encode the entire memory
just a constant number of
bits okay that's the input and what the
circuit
does uh first it does a bunch of
pairwise
checks um uh specifically each x
if every compilation follows from the
previous one
assuming that what you read in the
memory is correct okay so you're just
going to check timestamp
and state the changes okay
then you're going to sort all the
configurations
by memory locations which the address
okay so you're going to put first all
those which address the memory location
zero then all those which which others
the memory aggregation one
and so on and once you have that it's
easy
you can you can you can still do some
pairwise checks
uh to check the consistency of the
memory
uh locations so if you ever read a zero
in a memory location you check that the
previous time
zero was written there if a
configuration
uses blocks you make c copies of it or
configuration you may have you know c
pointers to
memory bits so you you have c pointers
that would be c times log t
so you saw each pointer oh yeah okay
yeah so
so good so if you have more if you have
more uh you you can sort it like three
times
yeah you can start it by the first point
and then the second point
and so on yeah thank you
it's a snapshot of what the machine
is is looking at at the moment so it's
like the timestamp the state
and just the you know the constant
number of bits that would do with the
machine is looking at but not the entire
memory
unlike the you know textbook
configurations
so the good the thank you so the good
thing
about this uh is that i'm gonna forget
about turing machines
so um you can think of your
overall model and you will have the same
thing so the machine can
address any bit of
memory by following a pointer
yeah so that's what the boss was asking
so thank you so if you're more pointers
you can sort by
first by the first point and then the
second point so so seeing it will
block two times prime and c double prime
and say triple prime let's say you have
three pointers yeah
so yeah that's what but you know but
probably you know two pointers are
universal probably but
i think the this pointer may be like a
red pairing so
you're just saying let's look at a
transcript of the computation
you say oh a time t i read from
i read a zero from position i that's
important
so you can call it a pointer or not but
you know and then at time t plus one i
wrote to position
a one to position j so you have a list
of things that could have happened
during the computation and then you sort
that list of read and write operations
first by memory address the memory cell
address so that they're all lined up
and secondly by time so that they're all
in chronological order
and then you check that every read
was reading the bit that was written
there last
and every right was you know
like he's saying without lost generality
you can assume one thing
one thing that's right
so you
um
yes so if you want to sort the t time
two times you can probably
if you want to just read and write one
thing at a time but uh
yeah so i think this thing uh
you know if i write the book on
complexity
i'll probably put this thing in chapter
one you know i
think it's pretty good uh again also
there's been some some talking about
the connections within algorithm and
complexity so i want to
you know maybe oh we're gonna use
observation that you know
sorting matters to complexity theory
okay so the
fundamental algorithm is important for
the fundamental reduction in complexity
theory
all right so let me go back to our task
which is uh
making this thing constant regarding
okay so remember that
what i need to do is that i get an index
somewhere here and i must be able to put
on
the children of the of the gate with
constant
guardian so each output bit of the
description of the children should just
depend on a constant number of bits of
the index
i and if you look at the picture there
are
basically three things that you have to
deal with okay so the first one
are the check that you perform okay so
maybe
i get an index here this checker needs
check i must be able to index
the children of this circuit here
the second thing uh the sense out is the
sorting right so i may
this thing is huge as i said t times
point maybe let me get the index here i
to index this and the third thing
is a little bit more subtle to see is
the plus one
okay so i'm i'm using plus one here
um and it takes a little bit of time to
see again but
uh you know i may get an index here i
must be able to access both
you know the eighth configuration and
the i plus one so somewhere i'm
computing this at this high plus one
okay so the first thing that i want to
to convince you of is that if you just
care about
ac zero reduction this stuff is fairly
simple
okay so what's there and also gonna see
the various sizes of things
so if you just want our zero so the
checks are trivial
because this stuff is small it check
it's a polynomial computation
in the size of a confused so just the
polylog t
gates okay and um
you know the index that you know you can
perform
uh you can completely index this sub
circuit in a brute force with the
dnf even all right okay so with
without even thinking what this thing is
doing
okay so the checks are small because i
just they just index
two configurations the sort is huge
okay it's about three configurations
this thing is not trivial but it's an
exercise to see that if you use like
odd even mersort networks you can
actually
compute the children with with a t0
okay and this plus one business is also
trivial because it
is a zero can add okay so if you give me
this index here i can add
one in we are you know dnf and get this
configuration here
okay so that's so that that you need
if you want to place this thing in 0
but we want it in nc 0 okay so
constantly guiding so that that's harder
and for that each of these things we
require some
some technique okay and i want to spend
one slide about each of
them if i time um
so first let me tell you about how you
get these checks
okay okay so these checks
are small but you know if adjusted
constant locality
they're still big right because anything
is big compared to a constant
um so what we do here
we actually use again a general
technique that allows us to
not even care how this thing is actually
done which is always
good if you can do it so the first
observation
is that this checks like pretty much any
algorithm that
does anything that's you know that is in
in the practice
are log space uniform okay so these are
you know decent circuits which are log
space uniform okay
so log space is in the size of this
small circuit here okay you can index
the connections on this thing
by log space machine okay this is true
like you know if i want for
multiplication for expression for like
all the standard algorithms and even for
this one
and then we prove a general result which
we call a spreading computation
that if you just care about the
uniformity and if you allow for a poly
size
change in the size log space uniformity
is the same thing a constant regardless
uniformity okay always
okay so we just hit that with this
and the check circuit are done
okay so we can apply this thing to the
whole circuits
because you blow up the size by a
polynomial which we can we cannot afford
but here if you make this thing a little
bit larger
it's okay and again you get the constant
regarding how this thing done
so that the technique goes back to root
zone
and it it's about adding
gates to the circuit which encode
configurations of the log space machine
okay however roots does not aim or prove
a constant regularity and because of the
reality is a little bit
uh triggered because you you can't even
check if the configuration is valid or
not so that should the new circuit here
will have a bunch of stuff
about over which you have little control
but uh
it will still correspond to a correct
computation
okay um okay so again
you add gates which correspond to the
configurations of the log space unit for
a
machine which index this and then the
connection within
the doors can be done with constant
locality
the second thing that we need to deal
with is the sorting and here actually we
tried very hard to
get a certain network uh that we could
index because ontario cricket and we
couldn't so the best
that that we could do is uh log depth
decision tree
uh and we read up actually in different
paper because we thought it was enough
of some interest to have this um
so to get constant locality uh we
actually
um going straight to routing networks
okay
so radioactives are a different object
in which
you can implement any permutation that
you want
uh including the one given by sorting
but you have to use
some additional and non-deterministic
beats here
uh and it actually was done in the pcp
literature since polish shook and
spin man but not so much in the newer
classical
literature um and if you use the debris
graphs
uh you can actually index you can
compute the children over index
i just by rotating i and exploring by
constantly which is exactly what we want
to do okay
and the last thing is this plus one
so i still need if you give me index i
needs here to index the
the next configuration um and this
you know it cannot be done with constant
legality uh we tried various things
and one thing that works is this is
actually
to twist the whole thing so i'm going to
use the radio network in a different way
so instead of using this circuit here to
compute the determination given by the
sorting begin by the sorting order i'm
going to use it to
implement the successor with respect to
the order given by the by the sorting
okay
the carry bits to be given to you as an
additional auxiliary
variables um so
uh we tried but it seems like you need
like
to double the size of of the index if
you're that which you cannot do
because if that means like squaring the
whole circuit so
so that's the that's one thing that we
thought about um
so um yeah so
this thing is a little so the issue is
that here
uh you know um
you sort of like you you go in the line
so you that all these things are
connected
by doing this plus one with this new
with this new system
um the checks can be uh aligned with
configuration so you always have the
same
the same shift that you have to apply to
the index to get to the next
configuration okay so instead of sorting
you compute a successor function
okay and that's so these are the three
main ideas
that go into this and i just want to um
tell you that time actually i don't
remember what time i started
to okay well i i got continued so i will
tell you i just said two slides about
the pcb reductions
um and uh is it over
okay okay so so just 5 minutes
20 minutes okay
so whatever i said about classical
reductions
uh you know also applies i mean the same
motivation that therefore for classical
reductions applies to pcp reductions
okay uh perhaps even more so
so in particular uh william's paper uh
gives overbounds from randomization
which should be easier to obtain
and the same issues are there so if you
the more efficient
the pc production that you get the
tighter the connection
and because beneficial introductions
were not known
in his paper and created with santana
he has a workaround their work around
so what we do here uh you know it's some
step towards
making them efficient uh but it's still
wide open
so so there is this paper by benson song
sudan and badan which i mentioned
earlier uh they give a pcp
which applies to any running time
including through the end
where the number of constraints is
quasi-linear which is what
you want and the number of queries is
polylog which is
which is not what you want but it's
something
and the combination of the query from
from the index is nc one
okay so me has later improved in a
beautiful result
this thing this boy log to constant okay
but we
are not able yet to exploit this so we
just look at the
original construction so we get a
variant
of this um in which
uh the computation of the queries
uh from the index again has zero cost so
it just required one so it's just a
projection
and this thing is easier to do than
before because here i'm allowing many
queries
so getting this with just a constant
number of queries it seems to be an
important
uh step and then the post process is
thin f
okay so this thing tightens some of the
connections but i don't want to
spend too much time on that instead i'm
just going to conclude um
instead we have seen that you can reduce
uh another mystic time
to threesat instances which have size
quasi-linear in t
and the ice clause can be computed with
constant locality from
the index okay and the previous best was
nc one
and it's now easier to get the new lower
bounds uh from cell algorithm so you you
quote unquote
just need to prove that the strong th
is false or the three thought is in time
1.1
to the n okay and we also get similar
but weaker results
for pcp reductions so one thing which i
think is interesting
is to to understand if
with respect to close explicitness pc
productions are inherently
more difficult than classical reductions
which we don't know thank you
yeah so can you give a new proof of a
non-trivial but
known lower bank for circuit that for
circuit classes like
you need something like that to
establish three to the end lower bound
but can you establish unknown like two
to the
sorry two times n lower bound uh
you prob you probably can yeah you can
prove probably you know
one plus one perception another i mean
uh
yes so just plug in the non-matrix
yeah i think so yeah right so no no i
think uh
well what what circuit lower bound can
you establish just taking sugurus recent
three four and so uh
i so there is a little loss that needs
to be overcome
because you're taking multiple copies of
the circuit but i i believe though i
haven't shared that if you started with
a circuit of size n
then uh you you get something that you
get over bound for those circuits but i
haven't
i mean as long as uh you know
if you're making two copies of the
circuit and you need a threesome
algorithm to be faster than
than the class but i think you you will
be but i haven't checked
but i guess it wouldn't be that right i
mean you you get like
french proof yeah
i think it probably yes the answer is
yes
the technical questions of when you say
local uh
constant locality so yeah that's wiring
how much do you need to compute these
three wirings like how uniform is this
sensors
well i think it's it's very uniform and
i think you can probably get r
which is simultaneously constant
locality and the linear time on a one
tape
theory machine but i have not checked it
because
there is really not in crinon i mean the
the spreading composition
of what we call uh you know
the connections here will just need to
take one step
of the log space uniform uh uh
describer so uh that's like clear time
definitely here it's like super simple
you you just rotate
again xor uh so i think it pretty
probably would be greener time in as
strict as possible model compilation
like one tape
but i've not checked that because for
these applications lower bounds or
circuits
you don't need that like maybe later for
you know threesat
for like start lower bounds you will
need the uniformity
i think i think it just you know i think
it's a somewhat cleaner model just
the locality bound as opposed to like
you know are you using one tape turning
machine or two tape to the machine
but
any other questions
you